drew Dawson from Topeka Kansas seems
like a for our show today huh Game of
Thrones nine I don't think so we're not
that long no yo what up Theo what up
Brendan my name is drew from Topeka
Kansas I saw a girl big fan of this show
Jayhawk love I got a king distinguished
Roger
first off let me thank y'all for helping
me get through my day sometimes man when
I'm at work I work a little factory gig
man and I just I could set up the phone
and run some king of sting get fighter
than King this past weekend and it makes
ours feel like minutes love it man so I
appreciate y'all for that this Rako is
is beautiful anyway my question for
y'all today is polyamorous relationships
three people is involved in a
relationship together whether that be
two girls one guy two guys one girl
depending on what state you're from it
could be two cousins and a nephew I
don't know but it could be three dude
polyamorous relationship kangaroo sting
yeah couldn't be also I would say put a
woman in there if you're even
guesstimating but you do what you gotta
do burn it three dudes Brendan they call
him two rivers three dudes two rivers
it's gonna say on your frickin tune ah I
just feel like it's so Massey me you
know anyone who's in a polyamorous
relationship just doing the damn thing
thriving
I don't yeah I mean look I think it
takes a lot of communication you know
back in the day they used to have a
polyamorous relationships you have to
did it yeah look at the Mayflower to
Penta do you [ __ ] whoever's alive on
there you know so it's like anything was
possible I think if you know anyone
doing it these days though like just
doing the damn thing I did look I'll
tell you this I had a guy come to my
show recently and he had two girlfriends
that was it and they were both cool with
each other and everybody was chill and
it was a just a loving community you
know and I believed it with this I think
as long as there's clear communication
because sometime it's like what are we
you drawn the line against really you
know if somebody if you can still love
someone but I don't [ __ ] know do it
I'm [ __ ] lonely and
medication also so kids to girls see how
it goes men be the guinea pigs oh I know
how it'll go man
you know it'll go fine for a girl and a
dude the way you you know know all right
I'm just spitballing ideas here bro you
seem lonely and sad yeah think of other
ideas fast you two dudes I don't know
what you're into listen if you can pull
it off [ __ ] yeah if you can't it's gonna
be a nightmare the pros and cons pros
you [ __ ] two different girls all the
time so fun cons you got two chicken
heads harassing you all to know I'm just
drama drama drama pros cons what
happened where are you where am I yeah
here's what I say dude can you bust two
nuts a day
Oh sometimes it's tough I can trust you
not so weak dude you older first of all
[ __ ] anybody seems like totally
outlandish these days I Rea rather do
some PlayStation or do something more
energy hate burning calories well dude I
just don't want to be [ __ ] somebody
bang bang bang bang bang
you know mmm then you have to eat or get
a drinker or a milk or something see
this is why I say get a food I don't
want a dude I don't want to [ __ ] anybody
you idiot I just said that didn't I
[ __ ] some goddess for no reason it's
gonna do it and play playstation I would
maybe do that you should do the Big
Brother thing what is it it's where you
get a big brother you just plays
playstation with you like once a week or
some [ __ ]
you know her that it's a black guy yeah
if you want I would do it get a big
brother huh you can do it we'll find
your black guy yeah I say King it though
if you can handle it I don't want some
white brother dude I don't want Jason
Williams hanging out of my house all day
I'm saying no I bubble spartina I don't
wanna [ __ ] yeah I don't want Paul
Wall or Bill Clinton [ __ ] hanging out
with me all day dude you know what I'm
saying I mean shout out to some legit
Whigs out there but still man anyway his
name
drew Dawson man thank you very much man
I'm glad that we were able to entertain
you dude and we do try our best when we
get in here you try man and I say the
communication is the key if you can just
be honest about it and let them know
what's going on cuz here's the thing I
think some people that are equipped to
love others can really do a good job of
it you know you might be able to you
might have the gift of being able to
love two people well whereas some other
[ __ ] jerk-off like old [ __ ] you
know cinnamon Wilson over here [ __ ]
Michael Jackson's little you know lava
lamp over here you've been therapy since
you were four brain you can't get a
[ __ ] connection with another human
being
dude get a [ __ ] owl hang out with an
owl oh are you something
owls are fake bro if you look under
their skirt they don't have a lot of
meat on them all right but yeah man I
say king of where we was he asked I say
king of boy I don't know anyone who's
not successful other than Hugh Hefner I
think he was miserable
right I think yours is old but his was
all about the sex I think if you can
find some Joey in there too you know
then you can figure it out better know
anyone who's doing I think we're on the
cusp of it though dude things change you
know things go and change so the guy
who's alone at night yeah whatever dude
at least I don't have some Sun always
bothered me a two-year-old son yeah it's
one way to look at it yes sorry never
mind man he's a beautiful kid Thanks
back up my broccolini get your life
together
I'm not touching